a conservative government that gave that
ruling gave the Scottish people a chance
to make their own decision to have that
self-determination they voted pretty
decisively that they wanted to stay
within the union and I think what the
Scottish people will want you know our
family there I have friends there they
want to focus on the things that are
affecting them on a day-to-day basis
such as the cost of living such as
educational attainment which is
obviously dropped under an SMP
government
can Nicholas sturgeon stand there and
say this is about democracy this is
about accountability this is about
equality and fairness and then say right
we're going to take the next election as
a de facto election
um she has deferred it on to the party
whether or not she will do this but
saying perhaps that it won't just be the
s p votes that will count but it'll be
parties that support Independence like
the green party how can she say that a
vote for the green party which might be
for a number of reasons nothing to do
with Independence is a vote for Scottish
independence in any legal states she
didn't speak for the green she was very
clear not to do that but on the point
about democracy
and this is why I always find
conservative is quite hilarious the SMB
have won the last eight elections and
the Mandate for Independence in the
Scottish Parliament today after the 2021
election is the largest it's ever been
it isn't first Minister alluded to this
utterly unsustainable for a nation Any
Nation as John Major recognized to be
held in a Union against the explicit
wishes of the people so some of the
people half of the people well as I'm
pointing out to you in Hollywood right
now there is the biggest ever MSP
majority for Independence that's a an
extraordinarily strong Democratic
mandate upon which to proceed now if
we're going to look for a specific
mandate to do something different at the
next UK election and that will be the
clarity of that the detail if that will
be determined I think that's absolutely
the right approach given that we have
had this ruling today
sucky do you feel that this could really
also really hit the conservatives in
Scotland in the sense that a lot of
people who perhaps supported
independence voted SNP because they want
independence they may see this as the
end of the road they may unlike the s p
that we have here in the studio think
that there isn't any legal options now
open to the s p to bring this and they
might think right well actually I want
change I'm going to vote labor and we
could see the conservative vote
decimated even further north of the
Border well look I've got some very good
Scottish colleagues who are working
incredibly hard uh for four votes in
Scotland but I think that the the key
thing uh for me here is I was reflecting
on the Judgment earlier today I I think
you know people don't want to referendum
what they want is for the government of
the day to focus on the issues that
matter to them they want you know across
the UK we know that their health
services are under great strain they
want Better Health Services they they
want better educational attainment they
want a better quality of life and that's
where the focus should be rather than
this ideological battle which was
settled in 2014 with the the cooperation
of the SMP with with this uh
understanding that it was a once in a
generation uh vote and I think that
should be respected
do you worry about the next election in
terms of I know you were talking about
msps but when we see the next general
election kierstama appears now from the
latest polls to be more popular in
Scotland among some people the Nicholas
sturgeon do you fear the growth of the
labor party in Scotland no I don't and
the reason I don't is labor are offering
nothing new at the very best it's Tory
light you know when they have the you
know make immigration work slogans in
one hand or they're you know make brexit
work posters on the other hand I think
they're offering nothing which will help
Scotland this is simply trying to win
votes from Tories in England and I do
feel for labor it simply will not work
okay Stuart Jose and Saki batty thank
you both so much for joining us in
advance of prime minister's questions
and our political editor Beth Rigby has
just joined me in the studio as well the
prime minister is going to take to his
feet at any moment
as soon as he sits down
speaker this morning I had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others
in this house I shall have further such
meetings later today
thank you Mr Speaker people in places
like Stoke-on-Trent North kidsgrove and
talk aren't getting the help they need
quickly enough when it comes to Mental
Health fellow campaigner James Starkey
and I were delighted when the Prime
Minister who was then Chancellor said he
would back our campaign every step of
the way to get a mental health nurses
into GP surgeries so will the Prime
Minister deliver on his promise back our
no time to wait pilot scheme developed
by the Royal College of Nursing and help
get people support they need
yeah well Mr Speaker can I thank my
honorable friend for his continued
campaigning on this important issue I'm
pleased to tell him all 1250 Primary
Care networks in England are entitled to
recruit up to two mental health
practitioners to work in surgeries I
know the BMA and NHS are looking at
expanding that and I look forward to
working with him to ensure that his
constituents in Stoke get the mental
health support and care that they need
we know comes the leader of the
opposition
thank you Mr Speaker and congratulations
to England and Wales on their start to
the World Cup and good luck for the rest
of the tournament Mr Speaker the world
cup doesn't belong to FIFA and it
doesn't belong to the host nation it
belongs to everyone who loves football
it's totally unacceptable that during
this tournament gay football fans are
unable to acknowledge who they love
and players have been threatened with
suspension if they show solidarity with
those fans shame on FIFA
[Applause]
Britain faces the lowest growth of Any
oecd Nation over the next two years
why
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker but
this country has experienced since 2010
the third highest growth in the G7
[Applause]
this year the fastest growth in the G7
and
employment at a multi-decade low we're
getting on to deliver more growth Mr
Speaker we're delivering freeports we're
investing in apprenticeships we're
protecting r d
and if the labor party is serious about
actually supporting growth maybe they
should get on the phone with their union
pay masters until
right
Mr Speaker
we want to get through premises
questions and you're not helping me okay
his in total denial we're bottom of the
38 oecd countries who are all in the
same boat when it comes to covert and
Ukraine and he wants a pat on the back
it's like a football manager bottom of
the league at Christmas celebrating an
away draw three months ago and it won't
wash so let's they don't like their
record that's the problem so let's try
it another way why is Britain set to be
the first country into recession and the
last country out
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I'm pleased that the right
wrong gentleman brought up the oecd
report because it contained actually
three very important points firstly
it made the point that actually in the
Years following the pandemic we're
projected to have almost the highest
growth amongst our peer countries
it also it also it all it also made the
point it was crystal clear that the
challenges we Face are completely
International in nature
thirdly and thirdly and thirdly it took
it thirdly Mr Speaker it supported our
fiscal plan because it's credible and
ensures sustainability now
or gentlemen would have known all of
the Halls
but he's not he's not he's not
interested in substance he's an
opportunist Mr Speaker
in four weeks Mr Speaker in in four in
four weeks in four weeks I've in four
weeks I've strengthened the economy
we've put more money into to the NHS and
schools we've delivered a deal we've
delivered a deal to tackle illegal
migration in the same four weeks in the
same four weeks all week
prime minister when I stand you build a
sit down but can I just say to you you
came to me quite rightly and said to me
we want to get through practice
questions I'm going to give short
answers please stick to what you like
well Mr Speaker there's only there's
only one party that's crashed the
economy and they're sitting there
yeah and I noticed this Mr Speaker I
noticed this he won't say why Britain is
set to be the first into a recession and
the last out so I will 12 years of Tory
failure well about 12 weeks of Tory
chaos for a decade they've let our
economy drift aimlessly before suddenly
cutting the parachute ropes and slamming
it to the ground and because of the
changes he's made a typical household
will end up with tax increases of 1400
pounds they don't want to hear about
these tax increases of 1400 pounds
contrast that
contrast that to a super wealthy nondom
living here but holding their income
overseas
how much more or order
you're still young I don't need any more
I don't need shouting don't need
pointing you might be a good example
when it sits on this front bench because
you're on the second don't suppose what
you're meant to do Mr Speaker I don't
think I want to hear this because of the
changes
because of the changes he's made a
typical household will end up paying tax
increases of 1400 pounds
contrast that to a super wealthy non-dom
living here but holding their income
overseas how much more has he asked them
to pay
or just order as I said to the Prime
Minister I said to lead in the
opposition I've got to get through this
list I need you both development and
think of other members come on
[Music]
Mr Speaker labor had 13 years to address
this issue and did nothing nothing it
was the conservative government that
took action and tightened the rules but
the problem the problem with his idea
the problem with his idea is that it
would end up costing Britain money
not not not my words not my words the
words of the former labor Shadow
Chancellor
oh
rather than peddling fairy tales and
gesture politics let's actually tell
them what we're doing to deliver for
this country a record increase in the
National living wage protecting Millions
from energy bills protecting the
pensioners triple lock that's what we're
doing for this country
Mr speaker thank you economy at the same
rate as the last Labor government we'd
have tens of billions of pounds more
and Mr Speaker it wasn't a trick
question the answer is he's not asked
non-doms to pay a penny more every year
he talks about the money every year
that's 3.6 billion pounds thrown away
because he won't make them take their
pay their taxes here how many extra
doctors could Britain afford with that
money
well Mr Speaker I'm pleased that he
brought up doctors because last week we
delivered record increases in funding
for the NHS
not just more doctors but more nurses
more scans more operations that shows
our commitment to prioritize the NHS not
my words the words of the NHS chief
executive
scrapping the non-dom status would allow
us to train 15 000 doctors every year
that's what labor would do
and we can carry on handing out tax
breaks to the super rich
or we can live in a society where people
don't have to go private to get a
doctor's appointment
[Applause]
[Music]
also hands sell 90p for every one pound
they spend drilling so they haven't paid
a penny in Windfall tax
Mr Speaker you may have seen this week
that somebody shredded ten thousand
pounds in protest at those propping up
an oil and gas giant but he shreds ten
thousand pounds every other minute
propping them up which does he think is
the more absurd
[Music]
Mr Speaker this is the government that
has actually put in place an economic
plan that will develop deliver
confidence and stability to our economy
and all I've heard from the owner gen
today there's there's no answers there's
no substance because there's no plan Mr
Speaker
he talks about the NHS we're delivering
record funding for the NHS but we can
only do that on the foundations of a
strong economy you can't deliver for the
NHS unless you have a plan for the
economy and he doesn't have either Mr
Speaker uh Mr Speaker every time he
opens his mouth another powerful
business voice says he hasn't got a plan
on growth
the failure of the last 12 years and the
chaos of the last 12 weeks are
compounded by the decisions he's taking
now he won't follow Labor's plan to
scrap non-dom status instead we've got
an NHS Staffing crisis he won't follow
Labor's plan to make oil and gas giants
pay their fair share in steady hammers
working people
and he won't push through planning
reform instead he kills off the dream of
home ownership
too weak to take on his party too weak
to take on vested interest 12 long years
of Tory government five Prime Ministers
seven chancellors why do they always
clobber working people
no
[Applause]
Mr Speaker he talks about leadership
this summer I stood on my principles and
told the country what they needed to
hear even though it was difficult when
he ran for leader he told his party what
they wanted to hear
even now even now he says one thing and
he does the other he says he cares for
working people but he won't stand up to
the unions he said he he said he'd on a
brexit but he tried to have a second
referendum and
and tries to talk tough about
immigration but he promised to defend
free movement
you can trust him you can trust him to
deliver for his party you can trust me
to deliver for the country
[Applause]
Ruth Edwards
thank you Mr Speaker as we debate how to
best help our constituents with their
energy costs 10 10 million people in
Ukraine are without power due to
Russia's barbaric strikes on the
country's energy infrastructure so can
my right honorable friends set out what
support we will be providing to our
Ukrainian allies to help them repair the
damage and keep their citizens warm this
winter
I I'm please tell my honorable friend
that I spend time discussing this with
president zielinski at the weekend and
talking to Ukrainian families about the
impact these awful strikes are having on
them I know the whole house will be
proud to know that we're providing
millions of pounds of immediate support
with generators shelter and water
repairs on top of the 570 mobile power
generation that we are donating to power
facilities across Ukraine we're also
working with the government to repair
critical infrastructure with eight
projects identified by UK export Finance
to be delivered in the near future we
now come to the leader of the SMP in
Blackford
thank you Mr Speaker I'm sure the whole
house will want to join me in welcoming
the moderator of the Church of Scotland
to uh proceedings this afternoon and to
thank him for his sermon at Saint
Margaret's this morning Mr Speaker this
morning the Supreme Court clarified a
point of law but the very point of
democracy in this Union is now at stake
and democracy will not be denied because
whether Westminster likes it or not last
year the people of Scotland voted for a
Scottish Parliament with a majority in
the mandate to deliver an independence
referendum the Prime Minister has every
right to oppose Independence he has no
right to deny democracy to the people of
Scotland
if the Prime Minister keeps blocking
that referendum will they at least be
honest and confirmed that the very idea
that the United Kingdoms is a voluntary
Union of Nations is now dead and buried
well Mr Speaker let me start by saying
we respect the clear and definitive
ruling of the on the Supreme Court
[Applause]
well I would say to The Honorable
gentleman that first thing I am looking
forward to also seeing the moderator of
Scotland tomorrow and I think that the
people of Scotland want us to be working
on fixing the major challenges that we
collectively face whether that's the
economy supporting the NHS or indeed
supporting Ukraine now is the time for
politicians to work together and that's
what this government will do in
Blackford
Mr Speaker it is right that we respect
the decision of the Court
[Applause]
now democracy and the very same breath
if democracy is to matter if elections
matter then mandates matter since 2014
the Scottish national party has won
eight elections in a row last year we
won a landslide the Scottish Parliament
now has the biggest majority for an
independence referendum in the history
of devolution the Prime Minister does
not even have a personal mandate to sit
in 10 Downing Street what right does a
man with no mandate have to deny
Scottish democracy
but Mr Speaker when it comes to Scottish
democracy I'm pleased that this the
Scottish government has one of the most
powerful devolved assemblies anywhere in
the world and and I'm pleased and I was
pleased very shortly after becoming
prime minister to be the first Prime
Minister in over a decade to attend the
council to sit down with the first
minister to explore ways in which we can
work together with the Scottish
government to deliver for the people of
Scotland whether that's delivering our
growth deals delivering freeports or
ensuring that the 1.5 billion pounds of
extra Barnet money can go towards
supporting Public Services that's what
we're committed to doing in Scotland
Gareth Johnson Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
last month just stop oil clambered up
the dark from Crossing causing chaos for
days they then attacked artworks the M25
and anything else to cause misery and
Mayhem these people are not protesters
they are criminals
will the Prime Minister therefore
consider making just the oil a
prescribed organization so that they can
be treated as the criminal organ ization
they actually are
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the kind of demonstrations
we've seen recently disrupt people's
daily lives they cause Mass misery for
the public and they put people in danger
the police have our full support in
their efforts to minimize this
disruption and Tackle Reckless and
illegal activity the public order bill
will give them the powers they need and
I look forward to seeing the support
that that bill receives from every part
of this house
me Mr Speaker one of my concessions
Vanessa has contacted me in floods of
Tears
her mortgage payments have risen by 500
pounds a month
she and her husband were already
struggling with high energy bills and
high Foo bills now like one in four
across the country they fear losing
their home
we are out of options and heartbroken
this was Vanessa
so will the Prime Minister introduce a
new mortgage protection fund paid for by
reversing his tax cuts to the banks
would he help Vanessa keep her home
Mr Speaker I'm really sorry to hear
about Vanessa's circumstances and I want
her to know that the plan that the
chancellor announced last week will help
families like hers up and down the
country because it's the right plan to
tackle inflation to limit the increase
in mortgage rates and ensure confidence
in our economy there is specific help
that the chancellor announced offering
low interest loans to those benefits of
those those owners on benefits to cover
interest on mortgages of up to 250 000
the chancellor is also meeting with
mortgage lenders in the coming weeks and
we will continue to do all we can to
support those homeowners who are
struggling with their payments Frank
Tracy you are Mr Speaker I recently took
part in the pitching in Campaign which
promotes Grassroots Sports and also
celebrates the volunteers who make it
possible every week so would the Prime
Minister join me in thanking those
volunteers for the incredible work they
do and also with top right football
taking a bit of a break at the moment
because of the World Cup would he join
me in reminding people that it's the
perfect opportunity to go out and
support their local non-league football
teams
who are incredibly welcoming and
including in that of course atherstone
town community football club bedworth
United in curls Hill town in my
constituency
well I'm I'm happy to join my honorable
friend in praising all his local teams
and he makes an excellent point actually
that volunteers have a vital role to
play in community Sport and actually the
delivery of major events and I join him
in thanking them for everything that
they do at sport accounts for over half
Mr Speaker of volunteering in the UK and
every one volunteer generates a capacity
for at least eight more people to
participate in sport and I know the
whole house will join me in praising
their efforts
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon Mr
Speaker since 2014 the SMP have won
eight elections and we now have more
councils members of the Scottish
Parliament and more MPS in this place
than any other of Scottish political
party every one of those elected members
were elected on a Manifesto and clear
mandate for Scottish independence
Mr Speaker what democratic rate does
this government have to deny Scottish
democracy refuse an independence
referendum and to keep us Shackled and
imprisoned in this involuntary and
inequal Union against developed Scottish
people
well Mr Mr Speaker again we respect the
decision of the court today with regard
to the referendum and we're getting on
we're getting on with the business of
working constructively collaboratively
in partnership with the Scottish
government to deliver for his
constituents indeed the airshare growth
deal is investing over 100 million
pounds to make use of his Region's
strong industrial Heritage potentially
making more use of renewable energy
that's the kind of positive project we
should be focused on and that will keep
on delivering
else Mr Speaker the Prime Minister has
rightly promised to recruit a successor
to Lord guide as his ethics advisor
promptly but would he accept that
threats to Integrity are often broader
than the job description of the prime
minister's advisor on the ministerial
code and will he therefore commit to
introduce the additional measures in the
new five-point Integrity plan on topics
like lobbying and conflicts of interests
developed with organizations like
Transparency International and Spotlight
on corruption to show he will walk the
talk and put party integrity and
government integrity at the heart of of
our democracy yeah well I uh I I thank
my honorable friend for his
comprehensive and thoughtful suggestions
as he acknowledged he knows that I've
committed to appointing an independent
advisor on ministerial interests and I
very much look forward to studying his
other proposals in proper time
Mr Speaker just three months ago
disappointed interim prime minister said
in Scotland and I quote we live in a
union which is of course there by
consent in by democracy and I did I
accept that
well Mr Speaker by the consent and by
democracy the Scottish people have
already voted by a clear majority in the
Scottish Parliament to have us say
through a referendum on your independent
future for Scotland
so it beg's ultimate question Mr Speaker
can this prime minister tell us if he
accepts Scottish democracy and if so how
that's compatible with today's Supreme
Court ruling that clearly exposes the
myth that the UK is a voluntary Union
and is upheld by consent
Mr Speaker at a time like this the
Scottish people want to see their
governments working together working
together on the things that matter to
them and I believe that that is possible
and actually he should know you should
know this Mr Speaker in his own
constituency we've been we've been able
to support culture and tourism working
together to bring the VNA to Dundee
that's an example of a positive project
it demonstrates the benefits of the
union and that's what we'll keep on
delivering
thank you Mr Speaker my right honorable
friend will be aware that the government
provides a slim financial support across
five firms for small modular reactors a
few other countries have woken up and
are seriously investing in smrs as
sizewell will not be running until 2031
at the earliest
should we not be doing the same yeah
yeah yeah
no my monitor friend actually makes an
excellent point and hopefully he was
heartened to hear what the chancellor
said last week that we want to crack on
with our overall nuclear program and I
think he's right to acknowledge that
small and advanced nuclear reactors have
the potential to play a key role in that
nuclear program alongside projects like
Hinckley and size well that's why we've
allocated 385 million pounds to support
them and like him I'm Keen to see
progress as soon as possible Dr Philippa
Whitford here thank you very much Mr
Speaker during the 2014 referendum we
were told that Scotland was an equal
partner in a family of Nations yet the
disaster that is brexit was forced on
Scotland against our will and we see
Devolution wound back by legislation
such as the internal Market act so if
the Prime Minister still claims the UK
is a voluntary Union can he explain the
Democratic route by which the people of
Scotland get to make a choice over their
own future
[Music]
but Mr Speaker the UK is a collaborative
and constructive Union that is
delivering for the people of Scotland
even in her in her own in Ayrshire
itself where we're working collaborative
with the Scottish government to invest
in Aerospace Advanced manufacturing and
space those are the types of active
activities that will bring tangible
benefit to the people in her region and
that's the right Focus for the
government
thank you Mr Speaker
um as a North Yorkshire MP my right
honorable friend will know how crucial
bus services are to our communities last
month a river stopped the only bus
between Selby and Doncaster meaning that
40 Selby college students uh had to find
a very short notice alternative
transport to get to College thankfully
the college itself stepped in to resolve
the situation
additionally across North Yorkshire
around 80 other bus services are now
under threat can you advise what action
he will take to ensure that essential
services are not withdrawn at short
notice and ensure that these are
continued to be operated across Selby
district and wider North Yorkshire
oh yeah my runnable friend is is
absolutely right and he knows that I I
share exactly the same uh challenges
that he faced in our rural areas of
making sure that our constituents have
access to the bus services they need I
I'm pleased that the Chancellor's
allocated funding uh for extra bus
services across the country and I look
forward to working with him to ensure
that that money Finds Its way to rural
areas like North Yorkshire to provide
the connectivity that's so important for
people to have opportunity and get
access to public services Olivia Black
to my register of interests Mr Speaker
tomorrow marks one year since 32 people
lost their lives in the channel new
evidence suggests that the boat reached
British Waters and that the French and
British authorities knew that it was in
distress for a very long time families
are still waiting for answers from the
Marine accident investigation why has
this investigation taken so long will he
commit to a full public inquiry
afterwards and does he concede that this
would not have happened if there was
safe and legal routes into the UK
well
Mr Speaker every life that is lost in
the channel is a tragedy but that is why
it is so vital that we break the cycle
of criminal gangs that are exploiting
people and trafficking them and that's
what the Home Secretary is focused on
yeah we have accepted over 380 000
people over the past few years because
this is a place where people can seek
refuge and Sanctuary but we must be able
to do that in a sustainable way and
that's why it's right that we tackle
illegal migration
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker Rising energy
bills are a challenge for all of us in
constituency for the north haikum are
very grateful for much of the support
that has been given by government but
with temperatures this week falling
below freezing in Lincolnshire those
living in parque Hills are particularly
concerned but when they will receive
their support so ask for the Prime
Minister can you tell me when and how
people living in park homes will receive
the 400 pounds which they're entitled
am I a my honorable friend has
consistently and rightly championed her
rural constituents making sure that they
get access to the energy support that
we're providing it's something that the
chancellor prioritized in last week's
Autumn statement I will ensure that we
get the money out as quickly as possible
she should also be reassured that the
cold weather payment system provides
extra financial support to those
vulnerable constituents when
temperatures drop below a certain point
Mr Speaker did Scotland vote for brexit
no did Scotland have Christianity no did
Scott and vote for the Tories no what we
did vote for go and Shout Me Down Show
if you don't have lessons
what we dead bought for only last year
was the right to choose our own future
with that in mind and given a previous
known answer from the Prime Minister can
the Prime Minister tell this house tell
us all in fact how a nation can leave
this so-called voluntary Union
[Applause]
challenges that we face right now are
those that require cooperation between
our governments tackling the economy
supporting the NHS and I'm pleased that
last week's Autumn statement means that
the Scottish government will receive 1.5
billion pounds in extra funding to
deliver for public services in Scotland
and that's what we're all continuing you
doing yeah Theresa May thank you Mr
Speaker Scotland is a proud Nation with
a unique Heritage it is a valued member
of our family of Nations a union of
people bound through the generations by
shared interests does my right honorable
friend agree with me but this morning's
Supreme Court decision gives the
Scottish nationalists the SMP the
opportunity for once to put the people
of Scotland first
[Applause]
and and end its obsession with breaking
us apart
yeah
[Applause]
I think I that my my my right honorable
friend put it very well Mr Speaker Angus
Brendan McNeil thank you the Prime
Minister one answer but it's obvious
that the route to Scottish independence
in their elections and we know prime
minister there's going to be many of
them no Mr Speaker inequality cost and
in France the middle earners earned 20
more than in the UK and low earners and
25 more this inequality is where the
cost of energy and the cost of living
hits people worse in the UK and it's why
I'm for Independence incidentally to
choose a bit of path but meantime in my
constituency there are both more more
off-grid fuel customers and a higher
rate of fuel poverty than in Northern
Ireland so will the PM do the right
thing on extend the 200 pounds payment
that's going to Northern Ireland to the
off-grade customers in my geographically
distinct constituency the Hebrides on
the basis of fairness yes or no yeah
Mr Speaker
last week's Autumn statement announced
55 billion pounds to support families
and businesses across the United Kingdom
with their energy bills and the
chancellor paid particular attention to
those that are off-grid in rural areas
by doubling the support to 200 pounds
for them and that will help many people
in his constituency and across the
United Kingdom Sharon redcliffe
all celebrating this weekend what we
consider to be one of the best days of
the year and that is Lancashire day
[Applause]
so will the Prime Minister though he
represents a Yorkshire constituency join
me in welcoming welcoming and like
pastry and local leaders and businesses
to parliament's day and join us in
supporting our proud history and bright
future by leveling up what we consider
to be the best County
[Applause]
uh well may I may offer my best wishes
to my honorable friend and indeed to you
uh Mr Speaker for Lancashire day and I
can put local rivalry aside on this
occasion to join her in thanking
lancastrians for their contribution to
our country and to wish her the very
best for today's event goes to norswald
Mr Speaker what we've heard from the
Prime Minister today is in essence that
no matter how Scotland votes Westminster
will decide but democracy demands
differently to that Mr Speaker of The
League captain and Kenyan right see AIDS
what if that other voice we know so well
says we say no and we are the state well
we say yes and we are the people and it
is the people in Scotland who have to be
heard this place can't stand in the way
of democracy and if this prime minister
with no man
is he seriously telling us that this is
a voluntary Union of equals
yeah well well Mr Speaker we are focused
on not on the SNP but on the people of
Scotland that's who we're delivering for
I'm happy to meet with the first
Minister as I continue to do to deliver
for them whether it's in her own
constituency with a growth deal whether
it's moving civil service jobs to
Scotland whether it's delivering
freeports or indeed the extra funding
for public services this is a government
that will deliver for the people of
Scotland and we will do it
constructively and collaboratively
order order I would no like to make a
statement on the 20th of October the
culture media sport committee published
a special report on answers given to it
by the right honorable member for Mid
bedfordshire
when she was a secretary of state for
dcms The Honorable member for ockle
South and Persia subsequently wrote to
me asking for precedence for a complaint
of a breach of privilege as was his
right
I declined to do so since the bar for
such a complaint is high the house
should only take action when essential
in order to provide reasonable
protection for those its members or its
officers from improper obstruction I
note the committee itself which The
Honorable gentleman as a member has said
I've missed Doris remained the secretary
of state driving policy of selling the
channel we may have sought referral to
the privilege committee but as her
claims have not been inhibited the work
of the committee and she is no longer as
a position of power over the future of
Channel 4. we are instead publishing
this report to enable the house and its
members to draw its own conclusion so I
considered it appropriate to respect the
committee's assessment of the situation
correspondence on matters of privilege
is private indeed had to grow to great
lens to ensure that members can write to
me in confidence on their new matter
knowing their communication will remain
private expect the same courtesy in my
replies The Honorable member has seemed
fit to give a partial and biased account
of my letter on Twitter and I await his
apology I gave the honorable member
notice that I will be raising this
matter at this time but I do stress it
is not the way we should be doing
business in this house
a little member of our film first
the speaker as you
know
the speaker as as you've just explained
the commons culture Committee in which I
sit published a unanimous cross-party
report about the testimony of the right
honorable member and the testimony she
gave to the committee and there are now
considerable public interest in what
should happen next I want to put on
record Mr Speaker that I deplore social
media pylons against you or indeed
anyone else I've been on the receiving
end of them and they're exceedingly they
are exceedingly unpleasant but could I
ask for guidance on what I and other
members should tell their constituents
of our integrity and politics in this
context if someone misleads the
committee what should happen next
can I just say Integrity is that first
of all Clinton's letter but only half
the letter is not Integrity in fact far
from it
it misled the people of this country it
certainly put me in bad luck with the
people of this country and I don't
expect that to happen and then impartial
speaker so if that was an apology I
don't think it was very good
listen Mr Speaker in following
honorable members of this house have
certain strict duties on them first
there is a duty of upholding the
institutions of this house clearly in
breaching the confidentiality of the
speaker's private correspondence the
member for ocal and South South Persia
uh has broken knowingly broken that rule
and frankly for that what if that was an
apology that was not sufficient for that
alone yeah but we also have a duty to
tell the truth now it is public
pronouncements he implicitly criticized
you Mr Speaker for not referring the
dcms Secretary of State the privilegious
committee but you were simply following
the convention of agreeing with a dcms
select committee of which he is a member
and when they decided not to refer there
was no Minority Report from him there
was not even a vote against from him it
was a unanimous vote so what he was
trying to do Mr Speaker was to blame you
by his partial release of his letter and
he was leading a public to believe that
somehow you made this decision against
the wishes of the committee the rules of
this house do not allow me
to assert whether I view the misleading
of the public as deliberate so the house
can make its own judgment of that but
this miserable half apology was
completely inadequate for the breach of
this measure
I'm going to leave it there for today
and I hope that I'm not reconsider the
ways but is on part no I come to the
urge your question I'm going to let
members leave before
well that was the end of prime
minister's questions or all the Curious
exchange there between the speaker and
another member of the House who had
clearly posted fragments of a letter
between him and the speaker and the
speaker arguing that this was
inappropriate certainly to publicize
half of a letter and and ask for an
apology David Davis they're instructing
that that was a miserable half apology
but before that we had prime minister's
questions of course but we're now going
to get an urgent question from Ian
Blackford let's listen in ask the prime
minister to make a statement on the
decision of the Supreme Court and the
rights of the Scottish Parliament to
call for an independence referendum
no no no
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I'm grateful to the right
honorable member for providing me with
the opportunity to address the house on
this important ruling of the Supreme
Court on the issue of the competence of
the Scottish Parliament to legislate for
a referendum on Independence
the UK Supreme Court has today
determined that it is outside the powers
of the Scottish Parliament to hold an
independence referendum
and I respect the Court's clear and
definitive ruling on this matter
the Scottish government's Lord Advocates
referred this question to the Supreme
Court which has today given its judgment
to Mr Speaker the UK government's
position has always been clear that it
would be outside the Scottish
parliament's competence to legislate for
referendum on Scottish because it is a
matter wholly reserved to the United
Kingdom Parliament
we welcome the Court's unanimous and
unequivocal ruling which supports the
United Kingdom's government's
long-standing position on this matter
people want to see the Scottish
Parliament and the Scottish government
focus on issues that matter to them not
on constitutional division
often rightly want and expect
their governments and the the United
Kingdom and the Scottish government
working together with the Relentless
focus on the issues that matter to them
their families and their communities
the Prime Minister has been very clear
and has demonstrated since day one that
it is our duty to work constructively
with the Scottish government we fully
respect the Devolution settlement and we
want to work together with the Scottish
government on vital areas like tackling
the cost of living growing our economy
and leading the international response
to Russia's illegal war in Ukraine
at this type of unprecedented challenges
the benefits of being part of the United
Kingdom have never been more apart
apparent never be more apparent Mr
Speaker
the United Kingdom government is
providing the Scottish government with a
record block grant settlement of 41
billion pounds per year over the next
three years and the people in Scotland
are benefiting from unprecedented cost
of living support announced by this
prime minister and our Chancellor it is
important now that we move on from
constitutional issues to focus on
tackling our shared challenges
I therefore welcomed the Supreme Court's
judgment and I call them the Scottish
government to set aside these divisive
constitutional issues so that we can
work together focusing all of our
attention on the and resources on the
key issues that matter to the people of
Scotland
Mr Speaker the United Kingdom government
is proud of its role as the custodian of
the Devolution settlement
the United Kingdom is one of the most
successful political and economic unions
in the world
by promoting and protecting its combined
strengths we are building on hundreds of
years of partnership and shared history
and Mr Speaker I'd conclude by saying
that when we work together as one United
Kingdom we are safer stronger and more
prosperous
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you for
granting this subject question
it is right that the UK government
answers questions today and answers them
quickly
because this morning the Supreme Court
dealt with a question of law that is now
a massive question of democracy you're
here some of the Westminster parties are
already wildly celebrating this
morning's decision but I think it's safe
to say that their thoughtless
triumphalism won't last very long
because this judgment raises profound
and deeply uncomfortable questions about
the basis of the future of the United
Kingdom
the biggest question of all is how the
Prime Minister can ever again repeat the
myth that the United Kingdom is a
voluntary Union of nations in 2014 the
Smith commission made it clear that and
I quote nothing in its report prevented
Scotland becoming an independent country
should the people of Scotland so choose
if that is true if his government is
still committed to that promise for he
urgently amend the Scotland act to
ensure that the Scottish people have the
right to choose our own future
if he fails to do that is he
deliberately choosing to deny democracy
because a so-called partnership in which
one partner is denied the right to
choose a different future or even itself
to ask the question cannot be described
in any way is he voluntary or even a
partnership at all
Mr Speaker
what today's decision does is cast focus
on the Democratic decisions of the
Scottish people since 2014 the SNP has
won eight elections in a row we have
secured multiple mandates
the question is
how many times
how many times do people in Scotland
have to vote for a referendum before
they get it yeah the more contempt the
Westminster established and she was from
Scottish democracy the more certain it
is that Scotland will vote Yes when the
choice does come to be made absolutely
because Scotland didn't vote for
breakfast brexit we did vote for the new
age of Tory austerity we didn't vote for
this prime minister and we haven't voted
for the Tories in Scotland since 1955.
what we did vote for was the choice of a
different future if Westminster keeps
blocking our Democratic decisions
lawfully and democratically Scotland
will find a way out of this Union
foreign
this idea that there was a mandate
delivered in 2021 of the holiday
elections is completely misleading as as
the as the first Minister as the first
Minister herself said in an interview in
the herald that it parties and when this
is when she thought that the former
first Minister their leader previous
leader Alex salmond was gaming the
system with his party Alba she very
clearly said that parties should stand
on both the list but both the list and
first past the post-conception system
and and and and the greens the greens
did not fulfill that neither did Alba so
let's be clear in in the 22 Hollywood
elections the so-called mandate less
than one-third of the Scottish
electorate voted for the SMP
[Music]
[Music]
in this case in detail for reaching an
Adam's decision and for doing so in a
speedy manner I also want to thank the
Scottish Lord advocate for referring
this case to the Supreme Court she was
right not to allow it to be lodged in
the Scottish Parliament before seeking
legal Clarity on this matter and we are
all in a better place now for that
Clarity having been put forward the
Supreme Court ruling is absolutely clear
and concise
at the lead of the SNP has just accused
those who are against independence of
tranquilism today nothing could be
further from the truth
we are deeply disappointed and angry
that their politics in Scotland is
paralyzed by this constitutional
grievance
it's now time for all of us in Scottish
politics to focus on the problems facing
our country from rocketing builds to the
crisis in our NHS and I wish they had
such passion for doing that I fear that
won't happen after the first ministers
announced that she will turn the next
general election into a de facto
referendum as an example Madam Deputy
speaker the s p have made such a mess of
our NHS that earlier this week NHS
Chiefs have been discussing plans to
privatize our Health Service
labor and perhaps our country's greatest
achievement that is not a majority in
Scotland for a referendum or for
Independence but neither is the majority
for the status quo there's a majority in
Scotland and across the UK for change
this feeling and incapable touring
government is unfit to govern this
country they've crashed the economy and
they had as big a threat to the union
than any nationalist
people in Scotland and across the UK are
sick of watching their incompetence our
national standing falling in the world
and working people paying for their
decisions but change is coming it's
coming with a UK labor government that
will bring economic growth raise living
standards and restore our nation's place
in the world so does the Secretary of
State agree with me that change is
indeed coming and Scottish voters Will
Lead the Way by kicking his government
out of office and helping to elect a UK
labor government
okay
um
might have definitely speak but no I
don't agree with him on his last point
my constituents Madam David speaker
won't be celebrating this outcome but
they will be deeply relieved that they
are not going to be facing a hugely
divisive Independence referendum next
October with all the other issues that
they face in my constituency people
cannot get access and NHS dentist they
cannot access a GP they can hardly get
an ambulance to come out and our local
hospital was overwhelmed two weeks ago
on that basis does my right honorable
friend agree with me that this is the
time to move on and focus on the issues
that really matter to our constituents
in Scotland
speaker my right honorable friend is
absolutely right and I know he's been
he's put a lot of work on this subject
in in the past the Scottish government
must focus on the people's priorities
public services in Scotland and are
falling behind failing in many areas and
it is important that we now stop
constitutional wrangling and focus on
what the people's priorities are that's
what they want us to do
it
is
well let's step away from what's
happening in the House of Commons at the
moment they're discussing
um the Supreme Court decision this
morning regarding the possibility of
another Indie referendum in Scotland
essentially saying that the s p has no
legal right to hold such a referendum
let's bring in our political editor Beth
would be here and Beth the SNP we've
heard there in the house and also
Nicholas sturgeon's speech a little bit
earlier today in fact let's let's take a
clip of what Nicholas sturgeon said she
said she felt disappointed after this
decision by the Supreme Court
while I am obviously very disappointed
by it I do respect and accept the
Judgment of the court in securing
Scotland's Independence we will always
be guided by a commitment to democracy
and respect for the rule of law let's be
absolutely blunt a so-called partnership
in which one partner has denied the
right to choose a different future or
even to ask itself the question cannot
be described in any way as voluntary or
even a partnership at all so this ruling
confirms that the notion of the UK as a
voluntary Partnership of Nations if it
ever was a reality is no longer a
reality and that exposes a situation
that is quite simply unsustainable
well Brett Beth um the fact it's very
clear they've lost today however they
wish to dress it up but but they are now
trying to turn this now from from being
about a referendum to being about
democracy yeah that's right Joe I mean
it was expected uh there was an
expectation that the Supreme Court would
rule in this way that it is not up to
the Scottish government uh to hold a
referendum that that has to be a
decision consented to by the UK
government
um so in a way the SNP uh were expecting
this Nicholas Sergeant uh the fast
Minister there uh now reframing it as we
thought that they would uh to turn this
as you said from a constitutional
question into a question of democracy
new heard Ian Blackford uh say that in
the comments that the Supreme Court
might have answered the Constitutional
question about who has the right uh or
to consent to a referendum but the
question of democracy now still very
much live in the minds of the Scottish
government who are arguing that this is
a proof that this is not a voluntary
Union that the Scottish people do not
have uh the power of self-determination
in this Union with the United Kingdom
and I imagine that what Nicholas
sturgeon will do will frame this as the
Prime Minister and the court in London
uh frustrating the will of the Scottish
people and she will use that to try and
build momentum for that second
Independence referendum look she argued
for this in May 2021 in the holyrood
election she was clear that one of the
big campaigns for her would be that
second
referendum and now they had penciled in
a date for October next year she is now
instead saying that the next general
election will be uh
campaigned on for the s p on the matter
of a second referendum so I think that
this constitutional uh question was
expected but the idea that this kills
off uh the notion that there will be a
second referendum is anything further
from the truth and really it will fall
in part onto the political parties uh in
Scotland in a general election to see if
they can begin to whittle down that
commanding SMP uh majority both uh in
the in Westminster where they hold the
vast majority of Scottish seats in
Westminster but of course they've also
won election after election in holyrood
so I don't think this is a an argument a
question that's going to go away this in
fact was expected and now Nicholas
sturgeon will pivot to her second point
about making this a question of
democracy and continue campaigning and
now use the view like grievance politics
that Scotland has been frustrated by the
overlords in London if you like okay and
prime minister's questions what did you
make of the exchanges between Richardson
and Kirsten today well what was
interesting about this was we'd
obviously heard a lot from Jeremy Hunt
last week about the Autumn statement but
this was the first moment that Rishi
soon at the Prime Minister answered
questions about the economy I'd say
politically this was safe for ground for
him he's a former Chancellor he's very
used to standing up at the dispatch box
talking about economy so I think in
terms of the Optics of it he was clearly
more comfortable he's had three it felt
like it had a good breakfast that's what
you said did you say that is weird
sounds I mean I mean if you think about
the past three sessions have been so
Torrid for him he had questions over
bravman and her reappointment extremely
controversial he then had questions over
bullying allegations the resignation of
of Gavin Williamson so he's had some
really difficult weeks this was easier
for him in terms of the politics because
he's more comfortable on the ground of
economy but in terms of the questions it
wasn't comfortable I mean there are two
issues that care starmer Drew out there
the fast is the oecd reports saying that
uh the the UK's forecast to grow the
slowest have the worst economic
performance of all G7 countries which
makes the argument that well this is a
global problem that we're all dealing
with that suggests that there is a UK a
specific element and of course the
second thing now is the issue of living
standards and living standards fall into
their lowest levels since 2013 a lost
decade if you like fall in more steeply
in the next two years than they have in
six decades it really puts into sharp
focus at the cost of living crisis that
people are grappling with and kirst
armor is clearly trying to use prime
minister's questions now to frame
himself as the party on site of working
people that was quite difficult for
labor with Boris Johnson because he took
so many uh working votes if you like
from those traditional red wool seats
and trying to frame uh Rishi sunak as a
prime minister on the side of vested
interest he used two examples three
examples there he talks about oil and
gas profits he talked about the failure
to more heavily tax non-doms which labor
claim would Garner 3.6 billion pounds in
taxation and then he also talked about
Rishi sunak's decision to delay that
housing Bill and that's about building
more houses because basically he's
facing a Tory Rebellion so again going
back to weakness of the Prime Minister
that I think is a longer term strategy
now for kistama Beth thanks very much
well you are watching Sky News coming up
next we will have the very latest uh on
that decision is the UK's highest court
or is the Scottish Parliament does not
have the legal power to hold a second
Independence referendum the SNP making
it very clear that for them the battle
is still on
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s the UK's highest court rules the
Scottish Parliament does not have the
power to hold a second Independence
referendum
Nico sturgeon insists Independence is
necessary to avoid the disaster of
brexit and confirms she'll rely on a
general election to deliver a mandate
to achieve independence is as strong as
it has ever been indeed it is a better
thing today even stronger
I think that the people of Scotland want
us to be working on fixing the major
challenges that we collectively face
whether that's the economy supporting
the NHS or indeed supporting Ukraine
an inconceivable cruel crime a man whose
wife and two daughters were killed in a
Nottingham flat pays tribute to the
family that died in the fire
a newborn baby is killed in a Russian
missile strike on a hospital in southern
Ukraine
Manchester United's share prices rise as
owners confirm they're open to selling
the club
[Music]
hello good afternoon and welcome to Sky
News at one Scotland's first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon has confirmed that her
party will use the next general election
as a de facto referendum on Scottish
independence she was speaking after the
Supreme Court ruled Hollywood does not
have the legal power to hold a vote
without the permission of the UK
government Nicola sturgeon accuse
Westminster of denying democracy and
said Independence was essential to avoid
the disaster of brexit
well I um obviously very disappointed by
it I do respect and accept the Judgment
of the court in securing